So Iran is going to stop complying with some
parts of the Iran nuclear deal that Donald
Trump voided bailed on.
And this is actually perfectly logical behavior
for Iran.
Iran is acting rationally here and this is
being reported in many corporate media outlets
and everywhere in right wing media as c, look,
Iran is bad.
Iran can't be trusted.
Trump was right to void the nuclear deal with
Iran, and these people are either deliberately
dishonest or they're actually just ignorant
to how causation works when time moves forwards
rather than backwards.
Here's what's going on.
Iran's president said late last week that
he is going to move away from the Iran nuclear
deal on their end, and it's likely that they're
going to start producing nuclear centrifuges.
They're going to start stocking up on nuclear
material, and immediately the reaction from
the pro Trump side was, look, Iran is terrible.
We can't trust them.
Look at what they're doing, but the truth
is this is Trump's fault.
This is not a show that blames Trump where
blame is not deserved.
When we talk about the economy, we talk about
what does a president control?
What doesn't a president control?
You know that that's the way I handle things.
But this is not Iran being a bad actor in
the irrational sense.
In a bad faith sense.
This is a direct result of Donald Trump canceling
a deal, not Iran, that Iran did nothing to
violate.
There are reports that are saying the headline
here is a run to stop complying with the nuclear
deal.
Trump voided the deal already, right?
Iran is not bound by a deal that was already
avoided by the other party.
And usually in Geo politics, things are complicated
and nuanced and there are many factors.
Causation is difficult to suss out what was
actually the order of things.
And is there a, uh, a causal relationship,
endless ifs, ands, and buts.
This is a very simple case.
Trump cancelled a deal that Iran stuck too.
So now Iran is saying, well, if Trump already
avoided the deal, let's actually do some of
this development because it's in our best
interests one way or the other.
And those best interests are to resume nuclear
development.
Obama signed the deal with Iran.
Bots of right wingers said it's a bad idea.
Iran can't be trusted.
Okay.
I mean there, there, there was reason to be
skeptical of whether around could be trusted,
but Iran stuck to the deal.
They stuck to the inspection guidelines.
We have no evidence that Iran violated the
Iran nuclear deal.
In comes Trump, and even though Iran did nothing
wrong, Trump says, bad deal, we're avoiding
it.
The United States is getting out to diplomacy.
Disaster of countries can't trust that from
one president to the next, we're going to
stick to our agreements.
Why would other countries abide by them?
Why would other countries even get into agreements
with the United States?
So once Trump says we're ending the deal,
and in fact let's starts looking at adding
more sanctions on Iran, which is what's going
on now, obviously Iran is going to do the
internally logical thing of going back to
researching nuclear technology.
Since that's in their immediate best interests,
they stuck to the deal.
Trump ended the deal.
What's the incentive for Iran to stick to
it if Trump is sanctioning them anyway, if
they're being in a sense punished, even though
they stuck to the deal, now that the deal
is gone, you go back and do some nuclear development.
Either it will get you something of value.
We know that nuclear technology is of geopolitical
value to countries that exist on planet earth.
They'll either end up with that or they will
get some other kind of deal where they now
have something they can agree to give up in
exchange for other things of value.
In some kind of future negotiation.
When the United States president unilaterally
withdraws from a deal that the other party
is complying with, they go back to what they
were doing or thinking of doing or planning
to do.
I don't want Iran to have nuclear weapons.
I never wanted Iran to have nuclear weapons.
And I'm for a denuclearization actually at
big, bigger picture.
Uh, but the policy of undo everything Obama
did turns out to be a really bad foreign policy
platform.
And this is one of the obvious predictable
results that we've been talking about since,
since Donald Trump said we're avoiding the
Iran nuclear deal.
Is there any other possible interpretation
and assessment of this?
I want to hear from you.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman and the show is
on Twitter at David
Pakman show.
Let me know